Speaker 1: There continues to be a real and
serious problem in the United States regarding
access to mental health services.
Undiagnosed mental illness, untreated mental
illness.
And over the years, we've covered conspiracy
theories and conspiracies and cultish thinking
cult like thinking by interviewing all sorts
of different experts, and they've told us
about the connection that exists to mental
illness.
Now, this doesn't mean every conspiracy theorist
is mentally ill, not at all.
That's not what this means, but we've explored
in detail the connection that exists there
Speaker 2: and how
Speaker 1: sometimes delusional paranoia and
schizophrenia or whatever it will lend itself
to be captured by whatever the conspiracy
theory of the day is.
And it can create some confounding factors
in figuring out what's
Speaker 2: going on and why.
OK.
Speaker 1: In the last few months, Q and on
the conspiracy group has been increasingly
focused on going out to Dealey Plaza in Dallas,
Texas, that's the site, of course, where former
President John F. Kennedy was assassinated
in 1963.
And something really interesting and kind
of bizarre developed.
Some of these people have started to say JFK
Junior is actually still alive.
This is this is the late son of JFK, the former
president, this is an important detail.
JFK and JFK Jr. two different people.
JFK died in 1963.
JFK Jr. died in 1999.
Two different people.
This is sort of fringe even for some of the
Q and on people like only some of the Cuban
people believe this.
But the idea is JFK junior still alive.
Now, the bulk of QAnon is based on the idea
that Donald Trump was.
In parentheses sent by God, sometimes it's
sent by God, sometimes not.
Donald Trump was sent to fight a satan worshiping
group of child traffickers, mostly Democrats.
Among other things, that the big piece, there's
an offshoot of QAnon that believes that JFK
Jr. is still alive.
Based on I don't even know what might be numerology
hard to understand it.
So that gets us to this past weekend where
there was like a it was like a holiday Q and
on rally parade or of some kind in Dallas,
Texas.
And I'm going to play a short video here where
you're going to watch and you're going to
be able to hear protesters saying JFK is alive.
Two people say JFK is alive and then someone
else says JFK Jr. two.
They seem confused about which JFK is supposedly
still alive, and some of them apparently are
saying that it's both.
Take a look at this insane
Speaker 2: video
Speaker 3: JFK is.
You want to go live so junior
Unidentified: more navy than.
I love your time traveling.
Speaker 3: You'll find out.
Karen, she needs you.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, so now JFK is still alive,
I hadn't even heard that before.
What do you think is more likely?
They don't know the difference between JFK
and JFK Jr..
And so they heard some Q people saying JFK
Jr. is alive.
They don't realize that that's JFK son.
And so they're just saying JFK.
That's one possibility.
The other possibility is they genuinely believe
that it's JFK and not JFK Jr.
That's the one that's actually alive.
Option three is some other type of confusion
that is, you know, good.
Good luck figuring out what it is now.
Again, JFK was the former president assassinated
in 1963.
If he were alive today, he'd be one hundred
and four years old.
It's possible.
It's not particularly likely, even if he did
somehow die in nineteen sixty three.
I'm sorry, even if he somehow didn't really
die in nineteen sixty three figured out a
way to stay alive without anyone knowing everybody
was in on it.
Nobody spilled the beans.
He'd be one hundred and four years old today.
Not super likely based on actuarial tables
for men born in 1917 when JFK was born, on
the other hand.
JFK Jr., also known as John-John, he died
in 1999 in a plane crash and would be sixty
one today.
Way more plausible.
Neither is true.
They're both dead.
But if you're going to posit that one of them
is actually still alive, I would go with the
guy who would be sixty one.
Not with the guy who would be one hundred
and four.
No evidence of either.
But statistically more more possible.
These people are really confused.
And to the extent that they are not violent,
seeing this is more sad than anything else.
The problem is.
Increasingly, there is the concern that the
Q and on people, when none of it comes true
because now they're eight years of none of
this stuff coming true.
There is the concern that as their predictions
continue not to come true, they will go over
the line into some kind
Speaker 2: of Jonestown
Speaker 1: type mass suicide, maybe even taking
other people down with them.
Let's hope not.
But JFK confusion at Dealey Plaza over the
weekend